here in the valley the 16 year old  student accused of sexually assaulting  and trying to kill a teacher at el  dorado high school has been identified  jonathan el torrillo martinez garcia is  facing multiple charges including  attempted murder and sexual assault  police say he went into the teacher's  room thursday afternoon to talk about  grades at some point martinez garcia got  violent and started punching and  strangling her until she lost  consciousness  ccea's president says change needs to  happen so something like this doesn't  happen again  is it going to take someone dying at the  hands of a student you know whether it's  another student or a staff member we  have to have some immediate  interventions to to figure out what to  do  because of his age martinez garcia could  face charges as an adult he first faced  a judge yesterday and is due back in  court on tuesday